Sports Illustrated senior writer Fox and
baseball analyst game for Brewers
Dodgers that'll be tonight on Fox Sports
1
Joe Buck and John Smoltz have the call
Kenny Rosenthal and Tom reporting from
the field will talk about both series
coming up today and tonight but Tom
thanks for joining us how would you sum
up last night what happened between the
Brewers and the Dodgers it's a lot of
fun I mean it's fun for me because I
don't care what wins or losses if you're
rooting for one team or another I think
it's been a ton of tension in these
games it's kind of a series I thought
it's been a manager series
I don't think there's a lot of
separation between these two teams you
see a million pitching changes that was
expected and last night I think you just
saw the Dodgers get shut down
offensively and you know Craig Counsell
did it with five pitchers it's pretty
much the fewest are gonna see in a
Brewers game in this series so there's a
lot of heat on the Dodgers going to the
game for tonight well finish that
sentence if the Dodgers lose tonight
done not over I still think they'll find
a way to get this series back to
Milwaukee hard for me to believe that
this team that you know I hit more home
runs and a team the National League
walked more than a team the National
League is going to lose three straight
at home so I wouldn't say it's a
must-win but you know you down 3-1 it's
pretty darn close to it so yeah I think
the Dodgers will find a way like I said
it's been an even series so far and they
did get the tying run to the plate and
that crazy night didn't last night what
we thought this was going to be the
Dodgers starters in the Milwaukee
bullpen and the bullpen hasn't been very
good for Milwaukee the starters may be a
little bit better than we thought
certainly last night but as you
handicapped abyss and moving forward
what do you think is going to be the key
for both one key for both teams well to
me for the Brewers Josh hater you know
he's the most important piece on the
entire chessboard of the postseason
because he's not just dominating hitters
Dan he's embarrassing them and he's
sitting out and there's a bullpen and
I'm sure Dave Roberts is managing this
game you know it's like when you play
the Carolina Panthers you got to account
for Luke Kuechly you know where is he
every play and you're always thinking
about hater when he might get dropped
into the game
because everything is going to stop when
he comes in he's been that good this
postseason so for me Dodgers they need
to score runs early as you mentioned the
Brewers starters haven't allowed that at
all in fact the postseason they've
allowed one run the entire postseason in
six games and look at their rotation
right you got Justine he's on a 17 you
go wave Miley who signed a minor-league
contract and tonight you're gonna get
Gio Gonzalez who had a four and a half a
with the with the Washington Nationals I
mean think about it the Brewers are
trying to get to the World Series and in
two of the first four games are going to
start Gio Gonzalez it's not exactly
Sandy Koufax Don Drysdale yeah yeah
somehow counsel makes this thing work
obviously he wants counts count Dave
Roberts he was in the you know keep his
left handers on the bench when Gonzales
starts the game and then when he flips
to his right handed platoon like a line
change in hockey he's gonna switch you
know to his other right-handed relievers
and flip them over and then you know I
got it set up later on so I think
counsel has really managed these games
very well but the key to me is Dave
Roberts and the Dodgers can blow up this
plan by actually scoring runs against
the starting pitcher he's Tom Verducci
the Sports Illustrated senior writer
working for Fox and the game coming up
tonight game for Brewers Dodgers that'll
be at 9:00 Eastern on Fox Sports 1
we had Kirk Gibson on yesterday the
anniversary of him hitting that home run
off Dennis Eckersley what do you
remember about that night bad memory for
me because I was at the game covering
the game and it was obviously at ninth
inning and they started working my way
down to the energy room because the the
press box to the interview room is
Dodger Stadium it's like a taxicab ride
so I'm like I better start getting down
there so I actually got down there to
the room before he hit the home run but
I saw it on TV the thing I did get to
listen to Vince Kelly's call live so
that was cool but I was like you know
I'm never leaving the press box early
again even if it takes me an hour to get
down to the interview room I missed Bill
Buckner's error in 1986 game six I was
underneath out
side the Red Sox locker room because I
thought the Red Sox are gonna finally
break the curse so I'm in the runway
leading off the field going up to the
locker room
and all I heard was a roar that I've
never heard and will probably never hear
again and I and I'm there and Dick
Schaap was listening on his radio and I
said what just happened and he said the
Mets just won this game and the first
person I saw come up the tunnel was Bill
Buckner and you know to his credit and
to Dennis Eckersley credit both those
guys and Mitch Williams I've been in
those three scenarios where those guys
answered every question after one of the
most tough or difficult moments
embarrassing moments Mitch gave up the
homerun to Joe Carter Eck gives up the
home were to Gibby and Buck has the ball
go through his legs and they sat there
and answered every question that the the
writers had asked amazing great and as
you know then those guys answer
questions over and over again because
you get waves of reporters there's so
many of them it's not like you just
handle it once I'll throw one more under
that pile and that was Mariano Rivera in
2001 you know losing Game seven of the
World Series did the same thing stood up
to the music so I remember in 86 I was
back at the press box Shea Stadium
working for Newsday back then and we're
all putting together a game plan about
what stories were going to write with
the Red Sox and winning the World Series
and you remember they flashed briefly on
the scoreboard Shea Stadium
congratulations Boston Red Sox in 1986
world champion yeah I say you love
baseball right there's no clock you're
not gonna take in me you know you're not
gonna take the air out of the ball you
gotta get that 27th out it's great Red
Sox and the Astros certainly feels like
the Astros are the better team the more
well rounded team I got sail coming out
of the hospital price gave us a little
bit here now I got Dallas Keuchel going
what do you expect in this series how to
plays out tonight I'm with you right now
the Astros two may just look like a
handful and all due respect to the Red
Sox and and all their wins during the
season but the sale situation is scary
you know he obviously wasn't right and
I'm not saying there was something wrong
with
in terms of the stomach when he pitched
last game but he was not really sharp
the last game but there's concern there
and now the the hospitalization puts a
little more worry on top of that price
not trustworthy
you know they managed to sneak out a win
in that game that was not a great start
so that's those are a handful man they
you know at home now that place to me
last year in the World Series that was
as loud as almost any place I've been in
the postseason you know only the
Metrodome for me was ever louder so they
got their hands boy I just look at
Euston right now Dan
and you know it's hard for me to see
where the flaw is you know where's the
soft spot where can you win a game
against them now Ryan Presley has really
stepped up in that bullpen so it's going
to be tough I have the Astros originally
in six I'll probably stick with that and
to me the Red Sox absolutely have to
have good deep starting pitching to win
three more games I and I also I know
that we're all everybody's hell-bent on
hitting home runs but I think the Astros
changed and I think the Red Sox changed
a little bit because Cora came over from
Houston and feels like he gave that
mentality of let's put the ball in play
we can still hit home runs when you know
if we need it or we can rely on a little
bit but I think the smaller things
that's what stands out with the Astros
they're not afraid to move a runner over
and do some small things there and I
think the Red Sox are trying to adapt a
little bit of that I even asked Dave
Roberts about that with the Dodgers I
said are used to are you too reliant on
the home run and he goes maybe a little
bit but we do walk a lot well if you're
not bringing anybody in doing the little
things and you're not hitting home runs
I don't care how much you're walking
here well you're right I mean listen
there's nothing wrong home runs I don't
think that such thing is hitting too
many whole month but you better mix in
less you said Euston in Boston do this
you know putting the ball and play with
guys on base but don't you think this
was the Yankees issue that I thought
they were built for the regular season
not for the postseason and and I'm
talking about just offense you know we
can talk about the pitching staff but it
feels like there's certain teams that
are just built for the postseason I
didn't think the Yankees were
yeah I'd say I do believe that and again
I think you have to have both you know
and for me the Dodgers are kind of built
along the same way I mean forget runners
in scoring position numbers with the
Dodgers okay I know we'd love to look at
that stat they're a team like the
Yankees that needs to hit home runs to
beat you and they hit a ton of them and
as Dave Roberts told you they do walk a
lot so they get guys on base and you see
I said home runs with a guy on first
base but they don't get a lot of hits
with runners in scoring position so if
they don't hit home run like last night
they're gonna lose games I mean their
path to winning the World Series if they
hit home runs period and you know Dan
that's tough to do everyday in the
postseason the win some games that way
but can they win enough oh I did want to
tell you I really like the Justin Turner
piece you did last night you know it was
just well-written and you know you
didn't have to have any sound bites in
there it was just it was well done
that's all I wanted I Thanks
I really appreciate that he's he's fun
to watch now he's an exception to this
you know hitting just home runs great
heart and soul of that team but I think
if you ask me to pick one guy in the
Dodgers to get a hit with a guy on
second base no doubt he'd be the guy
have fun tonight Tom always good to
catch up with you thank you that's a Tom
Verducci Sports Illustrated senior
writer with Fox and Major League
Baseball Network analyst for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]